I've been watching out so closely for
predators that I run straight into
something else life-threatening
quicksand actually this is a little bit
more serious than I thought
what makes this dangerous is if you
can't get anything to grab onto to get
yourself out of these situations with
this hot Sun you could die sunstroke ah
fighting against it will suck me deeper
into the sand
the way out is staying calm and making
only small movements
it's like loosening up concrete it's a
very strange feeling getting water to
basically lubricate and between all the
sand and mud once I work my legs to the
surface I can pull myself out by
grabbing on to the side and kicking
thankfully one of my cows didn't get in
here a huge heavy cow you're not gonna
be able to get it out by yourself God
exhausting before we go any further I
have to wash all this sand off you've
got all that grit in your clothing it's
grinding against your skin you eat it
all that chafing out here could lead to
infection
which is this gonna magnify the problem
now my clothes are clean I can carry on
[Music]